have a look closely at the page and if
you haven't already you can write this
heading in your actual book and the date
today is the 5th 5th 5th of August today
ok so here is the idea we have we have
these very many ways of measuring the
statistical information the statistical
data for a set of scores for a set of
numbers we've got lots of ways to do
this but importantly some ways are
actually misleading or unhelpful they
may not accurately give us a sense of
what this set of data is like so here's
what I'm gonna do I'd love us to imagine
for all of these that H dot is a person
let's just imagine H dollars a person
and let's suppose that along the bottom
axis on the horizontal axis okay
let's imagine that this is for instance
the amount of money that they earn every
year so all these people have jobs all
these people have jobs some of them and
less money some of them earn more okay
now we could change what each one means
but this is just so you have a vague
sense of okay this is what I think what
is being sort of communicated through
this graph let's think about the first
one okay the first thing is do you
notice all this data is kind of evenly
spread out do you see that it's kind of
this some that are on this side some in
the middle and some that all the way
down the really high end of things very
very spread out okay there's only one
set or sorry there's only one number
that has any more than one person do you
see it right there how many people are
there on that spot too it's just two
people two dots on that spot right so
now I'm gonna ask which of the three
measures main mode median right which of
those measures are going to place
emphasis on that little bump where
there's two people mean mode median
which one Anoosh the mode what does mode
mean again the most common the most
frequently occurring right so if for
example here's what we'll do why don't
we all just put some numbers on here
right so if just for the first one you
see I think I've given you six six
little markers here sir
my six okay no yeah
so I've spaced them out let's just label
the city let's just label it two four
six eight ten twelve that'll get us at
the top I think two four six eight ten
twelve now if we mark out the numbers in
this way when you have a look at the
dots
what would the mode be with the mode of
that first set of data be it's between
the two and the four right between the
two and the four so I think it's three
okay so four set a the mode the most
frequently occurring score would be
three but when you have a look at all of
the information did you see how well
spread out they are is three the center
of the group doesn't look like it right
like if you were to try and put your
finger put your finger and I'd love you
to hold up your piece of paper so I can
see it put your finger against where you
feel like the center of the data is can
I ask you to hold a piece of paper then
put your finger wherever you feel that
is so that I can see well so that at
least someone around you can see yep so
I think most people most people putting
around six yeah roughly around six do
you agree yeah okay fantastic
so in other words the mode right the
mode is not very useful to us in this
case because of how completely spread
out our data it is and the fact that
even though there's two people there
it's not very useful to say on most of
the group is around here do you agree
with that okay so when we come to answer
this question
what's the less appropriate measure for
set a it's it's the mode that's a bad
idea right because it's kind of skewed
is sort of misled by this so that was
set a the mode is misleading let's have
a good set B now you've got mean mode
median we already noticed you see here
there's another issue with the mode here
right it's the same thing you have this
big lump here but there's another
problem if we think now about say the
medium where is the medium which of
those dots is the median dot anyway
where do you see
go on the next sit-down on set B we're
looking at the middle one right now
sippy yeah very good Christian oh is
that the one you were looking at yep so
if you look at the top of that column
for set B right you could cross off
three scores to the left and you can
cross off three scores to the right and
then that guy right there that's left
over is the medium okay so the median
there is that a good measure of the
center of the data no not really because
you've got all of these people almost as
many of them and they're way up on the
high end of the scale so the median
there I'm gonna write this way the
median on this set would also be I think
it's also three isn't it it's on that
hump here right so the median there is
also misleading doesn't get you near the
center of the dial okay last one maybe
you can guess right what's the last
measure of center that I've got it's the
mean now why does the mean give us a
problem on this very last set down the
bottom what do you see
what's the problem with it this there's
no more than there's only hold on when
you say there's only one of each number
what is it that you mean by that
you're looking down the bottom here like
there's two of these there's five these
yep okay so it is true we've got
different numbers here however I don't
think that necessarily causes a problem
for the mean you just add them all up
and then you use divide by however many
there are there's another issue remember
I gave you an example of thinking how
much money they earn okay what are you
seeing here so I'd love you to um grab a
pen out which means maybe a different
color if you've got one and you might
notice the data looks something like
this I think that's about right
see how you've got that one score all
the way over there on the right hand
side okay with your other color with
your pen what I'd love you to do is
label that guy this guy it sort of lies
outside the range of all the rest of our
scores yeah everyone's kind of like
huddling up on the left hand side and
then
is that one guy lie on the outside right
since it lies on the outside we have a
really fancy name for it it's so very
close it's called an outlier because it
lies outside okay it's not within the
rest of my diner
okay now let's imagine now I put on
numbers 2 4 6 8 10 12 right here's now
what I'd like you to write down on the
bottom set of axes I'm going to change
these numbers a little bit okay I'm
gonna make these look like what society
actually is closer to so I'm gonna ask
us to label down here as like $50,000
put that on the left-hand corner and
there's a lot of people who earn about
that amount of money in Australia and
then see that one up the top there let's
just call that 10 million dollars now I
know some of you are gonna say mr. Wu
mr. Wu that scale looks terrible I know
however I will point out number one
sometimes we actually have scales like
this they called logarithmic scales
that's a conversation for another day
but more importantly I want you to see
what's the effect on the mean think
about this right how many dots do you
see on the page how many dots can you
cut him up nine nine eleven guys okay
eleven dots so if we took this 10
million dollars and added it up with
everyone else's money right do you agree
that ten million dollars is so large
that it kind of dwarfs all the rest of
the money that's on it do you agree
right so when I add up everyone's money
it's a it's about ten million dollars
and a little bit how would I calculate
the mean off of that what would I then
do but ten million divided by eleven
right ten million divided by xi just a
bit under a million dollars that's the
mean of the amount of income that people
earn on this scale is that a helpful way
is that an accurate way to describe this
group of people no it's not which is why
anytime you hear in the news about
household income how much
earng they never actually tell you the
mean in this case the mean would be a
million dollars and you would say but
there isn't a single person in this
group who earns a million dollars right
all these guys are way under and this
one guy is way over so the problem with
the mean here is that it takes every
single person into account even if that
person is way outside over here okay now
look back we're going to reverse this
right have a look at the different
measures we've got which measure helps
me overcome this problem if the mean has
this problem of kind of getting taken
away about outliers which one of these
would I use which is more helpful to me
what do you think Bhairavi the the
median okay the median on set C what
would the median be where would it be
it'll be in that second column right do
you agree so the mode could also be
helpful there so you can see the median
is something we can use to avoid these
guys each method has a problem but it
also solves a problem right the mode why
is this most useful well would anyone
like to tell me what their favorite band
is or set favorite singer anyone Merrick
Michael Jackson take some Harry you had
hand up Queen so what else does anyone
agree with actually let's just go let's
just just for the sake of okay I'm just
interested now to see what happens
those are not the choices I was
expecting but I'm kind of delighted by
this choices here's one of the last you
do I'm gonna ask you to go for a vote
okay now the soleus they ever decide
here ABBA
okay here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
ask you to either stand up or stay
seated stand out or stay seated based on
this question okay stand up if you had
to choose to listen to one of those two
artists either Michael Jackson or I'm
gonna make you choose a kata or
Queen okay stand up for Michael Jackson
sit down for Queen well
I genuinely did not expect that Queen
totally won Queen destroy okay alright
suggested do that
alright now let's think about this for a
second thank you you right so now if I
was sitting a second ago if I was now
trying to work out what's the center of
the group right well I can't really do
mean can I can i cuz I can't add up
Michael Jackson plus Queen and then / -
right somewhere in the middle is there
like is there a band somewhere in the
middle between Michael Jackson and Queen
okay you can't do the median either cuz
they're not numbers there isn't a number
in between Queen or Michael Jackson all
I could say is the most comment right so
lastly I'd like you to write down thank
you right the main time when we use the
mode you can write up here next to set a
is when da da is when it can't be
counted or it can't be calculated on
right you don't have numbers there when
you've got a genre of music or if I
asked for you know what's what's the
most common eye color you can't take a
calculation to that right well if I said
like blue and brown like what's halfway
between those that would be a whole
different color in between
tiffen mrs. Lee's who is both and that's
that's cheating so
[Music]